[Música]
condenan a 18 años de prisión al líder
del grupo ultraderechista outkeepers
Stuart roads fue hallado culpable de
Conspiración sediciosa por el ataque al
Capitolio de Estados Unidos del 6 de
enero de 2021 y es la primera sentencia
que se conoce por el caso
el kirchnerismo conmemoró 20 años en la
política Argentina la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner presidió
un multitudinario evento con tintes de
campaña electoral en la Plaza de Mayo
para conmemorar la fecha y al que no fue
invitado el presidente Alberto Fernández
amnistía internacional sostiene que la
policía y el ejército de Perú le
dispararon a los manifestantes en las
protestas antico gubernamentales y le
pidió a la fiscalía investigar en su
informe habla incluso de racismo que
legitimó la muerte de 49 personas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos El Líder del grupo
ultraderechista outhiepers fue condenado
a 18 años de cárcel por los delitos de
rebelión y sedición Stuart Road fue
calificado por el juez que llevó el caso
como una amenaza para Estados Unidos su
equipo legal dijo que apelaría la
decisión se espera que su condena siente
un precedente y que vengan otros
castigos severos para los involucrados
en el asalto del Capitolio de Estados
Unidos Manuela Cano con los detalles
se trata de la sentencia más larga
derivada de la toma del Capitolio de
Estados Unidos en enero de 2021
Steward Road fundador del grupo de
extrema derecha o keepers deberá pasar
18 años en prisión anticipamos mucho más
que una sentencia de 18 años no es que
esté de acuerdo con la sentencia pero
anticipé mucho más growth fue condenado
por orquestar un complot que buscaba
mantener al presidente Joe biden fuera
de la Casa Blanca tras las elecciones de
2020 el militante fue encontrado
culpable por rebelión y conspiración
sediciosa siendo el primero en ser
sentenciado por ese delito además el
juez acordó aplicar penas agravantes Por
terrorismo algo inédito para los
involucrados en el asalto del Capitolio
su equipo legal aseguró que apelará la
decisión
creemos que tenemos una buena apelación
en camino esperamos con interés la
apelación el proceso de apelación y
apoyamos firmemente a Stuart Rose no
creemos que sea una amenaza para la
sociedad creemos en absoluto
en la audiencia El juez lo catalogó como
un peligro para Estados Unidos y también
para la democracia el acusado por su
parte dijo sin pruebas que era un preso
político roads tiene 58 años nació en
Texas y se licenció de la facultad de
derecho de jeyle fue paracaidista del
ejército comenzó su carrera en la Corte
Suprema de Arizona una que dejó para
fundar a los keepers hace más de 10 años
ahora la condena de roads marca un hito
en la investigación sobre el asalto del
Capitolio una decisión que podría abrir
el camino a sentencias más severas en el
hecho que marcó la historia democrática
de Estados Unidos en la ciudad de
meneapolis residentes locales entre
Quienes se encontraban familiares y
amigos de George Floyd se reunieron para
rendir homenaje en el tercer aniversario
de su asesinato en un monumento
improvisado justo en el lugar donde
ocurrieron los hechos se dejaron flores
y otros objetos Floyd perdió la vida
luego de que un policía presionara su
cuello contra el pavimento
su muerte generó un estallido social
contra el racismo y el abuso policial en
Estados Unidos
vamos a Argentina con un multitudinario
evento en la Plaza de Mayo el
cristianismo celebró 20 años en la
política Argentina al encuentro
presidido por la vicepresidenta Cristina
Fernández acudieron miles de personas
pero no estuvo invitado el presidente
Alberto Fernández lo que deja expuestas
las divisiones entre el oficialismo los
detalles desde neuquén con nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoy
Cristina Fernández No dio la definición
que muchos esperaban de ella En este
acto no dijo quien debería componer para
ella la fórmula presidencial para las
elecciones de este año del frente de
todos la coalición peronista de gobierno
de la que ella es vicepresidenta y
además de la que es la principal líder
por eso su opinión su posición se ve
como algo fundamental en este contexto
para definir eventuales candidaturas
pues no dio ningún nombre Ella viene
insistiendo en que no es ella quien
Debería ser la candidata a pesar de que
se volvieron a escuchar en la Plaza de
Mayo cantos pidiéndole por parte de sus
seguidores que ella vuelva a presentarse
a la candidatura algo que ella ha
insistido como digo en que no quiere
hacer pero bueno no estuvo esta
definición de quién Debería ser el
candidato a la presidencia según ella lo
que sí estuvo En este acto conmemorativo
por los veinte años de la llegada del
gobierno a la presidencia de Néstor
kirchner su fallecido marido lo que sí
hubo digo
fueron críticas al gobierno de Mauricio
macri que estuvo en el poder entre 2015
y 2019 y una muy fuerte defensa y
reivindicación de los gobiernos de
Néstor kirchner y los gobiernos de
Cristina Fernández que lo sucedió en el
poder de ella misma y también algunos
comentarios respecto al gobierno actual
de Alberto Fernández del que dijo que En
definitiva según ella es un mejor nuevo
gobierno del que habría sido si era de
otro signo político además llamó a la
militancia a su militancia a hacer un
fuerte trabajo de base tal vez de Cara a
estas elecciones para fortalecer las
chances de sus eventuales candidatos o
para convertirse en una fuerte oposición
si terminan perdiendo las elecciones de
este 2023
amnistía internacional publicó su
informe sobre lo que ocurrió en las
protestas anticobernamentales que hubo
en Perú después de la destitución del
presidente de Pedro Castillo el 7 de
diciembre concluyeron que la policía y
el ejército le dispararon a los
manifestantes incluso con armas
prohibidas y agregaron que el gobierno
de Dina boluarte descalificó a los
habitantes del departamento de puno con
frases racistas que legitimaron las
muertes eumar esa nos cuenta más
racismo letal Ese es el nombre del
informe presentado por amnistía
internacional en el que se denuncia uso
ilegítimo de la fuerza y ejecuciones
extrajudiciales durante el control de
las protestas que sacudieron al país
tras la destitución de Pedro Castillo
una respuesta con sesgo racial que
habría sido coordinada y tolerada desde
el estado y no casos aislados No
encontramos evidencia que ninguna de las
personas que fueron sometidas a
ejecuciones extrajudiciales o asesinatos
arbitrarios estaban empleando la
violencia en el momento que se utilizó
la fuerza letal en su contra amnistía
estudió en su informe 49 muertes se
manifestantes ocurridas en choques con
fuerzas del orden la mayoría de ellas en
el sur del país lo que permitió detectar
un patrón de estigmatización en contra
de poblaciones históricamente
discriminadas así como el empleo de ese
instancias de poder de un discurso de
odio nosotros
definitivamente nos gustaría ver
a los fiscales y a la fiscal de la
nación que investiguen si es que el
discurso por la presidenta y de otros
están en el marco del Artículo 20 de la
gobernanza internacional para lo que son
derechos civiles el informe se suma al
pronunciamiento de la semana pasada del
relator especial de Naciones Unidas para
la libre asociación que se declaró
alarmado por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza que causó más de 60 muertes
durante las protestas se espera que la
fiscalía tome declaración a la
presidenta Dina boluarte la próxima
semana sobre lo ocurrido durante las
manifestaciones
en Brasil continúan las protestas para
repudiar los actos de racismo contra el
jugador del Real Madrid vinicius Junior
una multitud primero se movilizó frente
al consulado español en Sao Paulo y este
jueves las manifestaciones fueron en
Brasilia y Río de Janeiro en esta última
ciudad nuestra corresponsal Valeria
sacone nos trae el informe veamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
siguen las protestas en Brasil para
repudiar los actos de racismo contra el
jugador de fútbol vinicios Junior
estamos en el centro de ríos de Janeiro
aquí han salido a la calle los líderes
de los principales movimientos negros
llama la atención que haya tan poco
público en un país donde el 56% de la
población se auto declara negra y
también en la ciudad donde nació
viniciusé es porque nosotros los negros
también somos perseguidos aquí en Brasil
y hasta ahora la mayoría de los negros
están trabajando
[Música]
español La cosa más grave Es que la
nación española no considere el acto
como grave cuando decimos considerar no
se trata de la narrativa que Es evidente
y sí de la falta de acción la falta de
energía de compromiso y responsabilidad
que de hecho podría proteger la dignidad
la identidad y la humanidad de vicios
Junior como hombre negro incluso
incompatible con el código penal español
que en el artículo 510 castiga la
práctica del racismo
esta mañana esos mismos líderes de los
movimientos negros han entregado en el
consulado de España en Río de Janeiro
una carta firmada por 150 instituciones
piden que se cumpla la ley fuera de
Brasil donde el racismo es un crimen y
exigen medidas fuertes contra el racismo
hasta aquí este Informativo en Francia
24 Gracias por acompañarnos los
invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]